what is the best way to know if you have high
cortisol what is cortisol cortisol is the main
stress hormone and if cortisol is too high
there's a lot of problems that could happen
in your body i've done a lot of videos on this
let me go down the list to give you some ideas
on what happens when your cortisol is too high
you get belly fat you lose protein in your thigh
muscles and your buttocks okay so you lose your
butt and your thighs what what's not going to
do your knees it's going to make your knees very
painful and weak especially when you're climbing
stairs your blood pressure might increase first
starting with the systolic that's the top number
and then ending up with the diastolic 2.
allergies asthma acne anxiety low tolerance
to stress people start really getting on your
nerves especially slow drivers inflammation
why because cortisol is the main anti-inflammatory
so if you don't have it you fill up with
inflammation it could be anywhere back pain
whatever blood sugar problems you can even
end up becoming a diabetic if there's too much
cortisol this is why when people get injected with
prednisone for example where they use prednisone a
lot sometimes they can become a diabetic cravings
for carbs and breads okay that would be one way
to know that you have a problem with cortisol
decreased libido decreased potassium
because potassium goes through you
and that's a problem because potassium is needed
for so many things like energy relaxing you
balancing fluids it's a main electrolyte etc etc
you may tend to hold salts and that's why you have
edema as well but also you will lose something
that is involved with making acids okay and
hydrochloric acid so you end up with digestive
problems because you don't have enough acid
and your blood ph can go more on the alkaline side
not the acid side that a lot of times people think
more alkaline and that can give you a whole
series of additional problems but in addition to
all these symptoms one of the best ways to know
you have high cortisol is the time you wake up
at night typically it's going to be about two
o'clock in the morning it could be a little bit
later like 2 30 a.m but between 2 and 2 30 a.m
in the morning that's when you become awake okay
now i had this problem for years and i didn't
know what it was it was driving me crazy it was
torture because i would get up in the middle of
night and of course i had restless leg syndrome
too but i just wake up and i would start to
think and analyze and solve problems and worry
for hours and then when i finally went to sleep
that was around eight o'clock so the pattern
for high cortisol is you wake up at 2 a.m or 2
30 a.m and then you finally can get to bed right
around 8 a.m when you're supposed to wake up right
why is that because cortisol follows a circadian
wave and cortisol normally is supposed to be the
lowest at 2 a.m okay in the highest at 8 a.m in
the morning so everything is kind of backwards and
so when you should be sleeping you're most awake
when you should be awake you're mostly asleep
and then also you might have a problem with
midday right around let's say um two o'clock p.m
or three o'clock or you just want to take a nap
so that's the pattern of high cortisol you
can also do a saliva test there's also a hair
analysis i don't know if they're still doing it
now but that's a really good analysis they check
your hair because if you test your cortisol
with your blood you're only looking at your
cortisol at one time of the day as compared to the
hair which gives you an overall average of what's
going on with cortisol or a saliva test which is
good which you're measuring like every four hours
through a whole period of time to find out what's
happening on this pattern so the question is what
do you do about it if you have symptoms
of high cortisol well you got to find out
what or who is causing your stress do something
to improve that okay walking long walks in nature
very very important physical work is a little
better than exercise even exercise is really good
but physical work to the point where you're
you can get tired because it also doesn't
just deplete you of the excess energy the nervous
energy but it gets your attention off problems b1
essential nutritional yeast is one of the
best sources and lots of it vitamin d3
vital okay and another reason why vitamin d
is good is because cortisol tends to block the
storage of vitamin d as well as the ability to
use vitamin d people with high cortisol usually
are always deficient in vitamin d and vitamin
d is also good for depression and vitamin d
acts like cortisol in the body with all the side
effects so it's not necessarily going to give
you more cortisol it'll help you regulate
or balance cortisol that you already have
potassium magnesium are the two minerals
that are physiological tranquilizers they're
key minerals that help relax the nervous system
and usually if you have high cortisol you're
going to be deficient in both of these so taking
those either an electrolyte or in food is very
important and then apple cider vinegar why because
you have alkalosis and we need to acidify the body
so then you can start absorbing the minerals
and breaking down protein very very important
i have a lot more videos on cortisol i'll put
the links down below but thanks for watching
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story
please share it in the link down below